entre stéphanie et les super héros c'est
une histoire d'amour c'est lui l'homme
chauve souris qui la ramène à ses désirs
passer le film batman begins et cette
illustration de david espo ont un effet
immédiat
elle doit reprendre le dessin j'ai
replongé dans ma passion grâce à batman
et puis une balle grâce à battre pas
debout j'ai commencé à faire quelques
petites pensions à être invitée sur des
festivals comics un petit peu à droite
et à gauche de conventions en convention
stéphanie alias lucky star pseudo
hommage à son défunt petit chat se fait
connaître dans l'univers du comics lors
de la dernière comic con' de paris elle
est finaliste du concours d'illustration
avec son venom voilà j'ai été troisième
la troisième
j'étais hyper contente en fait je veux
entourage qui était déçue pour moi gb
non mais moi je suis heureuse j'ai fini
troisième au concours de dessin et
j'étais la seule fille à être retenus
dans lés dans les 30 participants les 30
derniers sa technique au stylo bic et
aquarelles impressionne le jury mais ce
qui lui plaît avant tout dans les
conventions ce sont les rencontres
j'étais en train de combattre iron man
et là en fait les deux enfants il était
face à iron man
il avait lise c'est ça qui est génial
dans les conventions c'est quand les
enfants ont fait rencontre le rire ou
coin qui voilà bah ouais je peux pas
résister quand je croise batman son coup
de coeur pour batman ne serait rien sans
le soutien indéfectible de son mari
christian l'accompagnent à chaque
convention les guidant ses choix et
critique ses dessins alors on s'amuse à
dire avec mon mari
moi c'est le guide ses stars voilà câble
et puis c'est rigolo maintenant quand je
suis invité en convention cette faille
christian il est là concernant mon mari
christian iv bah oui ni non
son plus grand fan c'est mon fan numéro
c'est important en même temps cette
passion connu une re découverte sur le
tard il la partage avec leurs amis et
les entraînent dans leur univers de
science-fiction pourtant bien éloignée
je me mets avoir déguisé en dorman c'est
le couple d'architectes lui vient même
en aide pour les perspectives de ses
dessins car stéphanie multiplie les
projets elle a été choisie par un
éditeur pour illustrer une histoire
d'amour dans une célèbre bd américaine
édité pour la première fois en france ne
l'a en ce moment elle travaille sur un
captain america à moto pour un livre
solidaire dont les bénéfices seront
reversés à une association d'enfants
malades
son plus grand projet c'est sa propre bd
le scénario lui est venu tout seul un
cauchemar qu'elle a précieusement noté
est conservé et donc du coup je fais une
architecture très sombre et très noir et
un peu plus les bâtiments bon genre
comme le film metropolis ou dark city
pendant quelque chose de très noir et de
très présente très souvent et pour
dessiner son personnage principal
stéphanie s'inspire de son mari sont
vrais super héros